.
Gut.
"Container information".
So, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Oh Gott, nein!
Tag 1 im neuen Leben
von Auswanderer Marco Schommer.
Ja, das sind jetzt keine guten News.
Jetzt kommt der schwierigste Moment.
Die Schommers verabschiedeten sich
in der letzten Folge
von Verwandten und Freunden
in der Schweiz.
In Ruanda wollen sie
ein Fitnessstudio eröffnen.
Achtung, Yannis
mit einem Schwertransport.
Familie Caboussat
räumte ihr Haus im Emmental.
Ein über 100 Jahre alter Wasserturm
an der Nordsee
ist ihr Projekt für die Zukunft.
Und auf und davon nach Spanien
gingen Corinne und Ralf Waldburger.
Wunderschön.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Danke.
Im sonnigen Süden
planen sie ein Hundehotel.
Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
# Uf u dervo ...
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
In Benissa an der Costa Blanca
wird es Morgen.
Mehr als 300 Tage pro Jahr
scheint hier die Sonne.
Vor gut 12 Std. sind Corinne
Waldburger und ihr Mann Ralf
in Spanien angekommen.
Die erste Nacht
verbrachten sie im Poolhaus.
Da guckte jemand hervor.
Caruso?
Ich glaube, er liegt da drunter.
Schätzchen.
Ich befürchte,
dass er da drunter liegt.
Caruso? Ja, da hinten ist er.
Schätzchen, du bist
in der hintersten Ecke.
Jö.
Das neue Daheim scheint Kater Caruso
noch nicht ganz geheuer zu sein.
Er hat getrunken, sein Geschäft
erledigt - von daher sind wir froh.
Gehen wir einen Kaffee trinken?
Schau mal, wie schön.
Jetzt gibt es einen Kaffee.- Genau.
Okay, los, komm.
- Die Katze darf nicht raus.
Es gibt noch einen Geheimgang.
- Oh, schau mal.
Da hat es Baumnüsse.
- Alles wunderbar. Baumnüsse?
Ah, ja. Voll.
Cool.
Das müssen wir rasch sitzen lassen.
- Ja.
Die Schweizer haben das Anwesen
vor wenigen Monaten gekauft.
Jetzt können sie 6'600 m2 Land
ihr Eigen nennen.
Darauf stehen zwei Häuser.
Das Pool- und das Wohnhaus.
Wir benutzen diese Küche.
Die andere Küche ist zu klein
und ist weniger praktisch.
Mami und Papi haben uns gestern
schon ein paar Dinge gekauft,
weil heute ein Feiertag ist.
Den Kühlschrank
haben sie uns bereits gefüllt.
Das sind ein paar Dinge.
Damit können wir am Anfang
überleben.* Sie lacht. *
Wir brauchen noch Pflästerchen.
- Habe ich in der Hosentasche.
Die Kaffeemaschine
ist vom Vorbesitzer.
Ralf und seine Frau
haben das Inventar übernommen.
Wir müssen sie
noch richtig einstellen.
Die Kaffeemaschine ...
Schatz, wir können am 1. November
draussen Kaffee trinken.
In kurzen Hosen.
- Das getraue ich mich nicht.
Die neue Heimat zeigt sich für
Waldburgers von ihrer besten Seite.
* Lockere Musik *
* Möwen kreischen,
die Kirchturmuhr schlägt. *
Wer den Tag am Meer beginnen kann,
darf sich glücklich schätzen.
In Cuxhaven ist das möglich.
* Vogelgezwitscher *
* Sanfte Klavierakkorde *
Während die Stadt langsam erwacht,
erreichen zwei Autos
mit Schweizer Kennzeichen ihr Ziel.
Geschafft!
Familie Caboussat hat die Nacht
auf der Autobahn verbracht.
Rund 1'000 km sind es
vom Emmental bis an die Nordsee.
Das war hart.
Wir sind eigentlich
alles am Stück gefahren.
Wir sind nicht irgendwo ...
... in ein Hotel.
Wir haben im Auto
etwa 3 Std. geschlafen.
Dann machten wir
noch eine weitere Pause.
Jetzt spürt man es etwas.
Ist das dort unser Parkplatz?
- Der da? Ja.
Angeschrieben?
- Nein.
Genau deswegen ist es unserer.
Ein Mehrfamilienhaus
in der Nähe des Stadtzentrums.
Caboussat ist bereits angeschrieben.
Sehr gut.
Hier befindet sich
die neue Wohnung der Familie.
Mirabelle und Alain
haben sie bei ihrem letzten Besuch
in Cuxhaven entdeckt -
und gleich gemietet.
Vier Zimmer, 100 m2.
Viel weniger als in Langnau.
Dort besass die Familie
ein grosses Einfamilienhaus.
Ab jetzt müssen sie zusammenrücken.
So lange,
bis der Wasserturm fertig ist.
Den könnte man auch wechseln.
Vom Berner Mittelland an
den äussersten Zipfel Deutschlands,
ans Wattenmeer.
Fischerei und Tourismus
prägen Cuxhaven.
Eine Stadt mit gut 50'000 Einwohnern.
So, jetzt kann ich auch helfen.
Du musst oben managen,
was wo hinkommt.
Ja, aber ich nehme etwas
mit nach oben.
Ursprünglich wollte die Familie
direkt in den Wasserturm ziehen:
in eine provisorisch renovierte
Wohnung im Erdgeschoss.
Aber der Baubeginn verzögerte sich.
Caboussats mussten
nach einer Alternative suchen.
Das hier ist eine Übergangslösung.
Wir hätten nie
solche Lampen installiert.
Aber es ist natürlich
alles praktisch, was schon da ist.
Von den Räumlichkeiten her
ist es in Ordnung.
Wenn wir wieder gehen, müssen wir
weniger putzen. Das ist von Vorteil.
Ah, da muss ich gleich ...
Mal sehen,
ob die Stühle noch halten.
* Mirabelle lacht. *
Das ist interessant.
Ich habe wirklich Rückenschmerzen.
Es hat mich immer gezwickt.
Beim Autofahren
war es am schlimmsten.
Jetzt geht es wieder relativ gut.
Ich glaube,
Bewegung ist trotzdem das Beste.
Umziehen tut gut.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Es macht einen locker.
Ja.
Und gibt einen gesunden,
tiefen Schlaf.
Ja, definitiv.
* Lockere Musik *
* Hupen, Strassenlärm *
Knapp südlich des Äquators,
auf 1'500 m ü.M.,
liegt Kigali.
In der Hauptstadt Ruandas
liegt das neue Zuhause von Dianne
Schommer und ihrem Mann Marco.
* Dynamische Musik *
* Sie spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Dianne ist ohne ihren Mann
vorausgereist.
Vier Wochen ist sie schon hier
und bereitet alles
für die gemeinsame Auswanderung vor.
Uff!
Sport.
Ich gehe den Raum anschauen.
Für den Sport,
also für den Fitnessplatz.
Seit ihrer Ankunft
sucht die Zumba-Trainerin
nach einem geeigneten Ort
für ihr Fitnessstudio.
Mehrere Immobilien
hat sie bereits besichtigt.
Nice.
Das Problem: Geschäftsflächen
an guter Lage sind rar.
Die Stadt wächst ständig
und die Nachfrage ist gross.
So nice. It's beautiful.
* Sie sprechen Kinyarwanda. *
Okay.
Sie bringen den Schlüssel,
um zu schauen.
Ich will auch reinschauen,
wie die Badezimmer sind.
Aber es ist schön, nicht?
Megaschön, gross.
(Englisch)
Die Räumlichkeiten müssen von der
Grösse passen, aber auch fürs Budget.
Neben Geräten
für Kraft- und Ausdauertraining
möchte die 49-Jährige
auch verschiedene Kurse anbieten.
Schön.
Maximal 2'000 $ Miete
kann sie im Monat bezahlen.
Nach dem Sport
kann man sich hier hinsetzen.
Vielleicht kann ich eine Bar ...
... mit Shakes, Proteinshakes,
kann ich auch hier ...
Es ist schön.
Mega.
Also wenn es mit dem Geld passt ...
* Trommelschläge *
Dann geht es ans Eingemachte.
Im Monat sind es 5'000 $.
Das ist viel.
Das ist mega viel.
Zu teuer, Dianne muss weitersuchen.
* Lockere Musik *
Es muss etwas nach vorne.
Willst du es unten?
Es geht einfacher zum Heben.
Oh, oh, oh ...
- Das war superschnell.
Okay.
Man darf es nicht kippen.
Es ist nicht durchdacht.
Corinne und Ralf
wollen so schnell wie möglich
mit dem Bau ihres Hundehotels
beginnen.
Doch zuerst müssen sie
ihr Wohnhaus renovieren.
Jetzt gehst du schnell ...
So, genau. Wir können es
gleich an die Wand stellen.
Wir haben wenig Möbel mitgenommen.
Wir haben ein Möbelstück, das wir
ins Schlafzimmer stellen möchten.
Eines, das wir mitgebracht haben.
100 Schachteln, zwei Sideboards
und ein Metallgestell -
mehr haben sie nicht
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Was von den vorhandenen Möbeln noch
brauchbar ist, wollen sie behalten.
Den Rest kaufen sie neu.
Mal im Badzimmer schauen.
Da hat es Dinge, von denen ich nicht
weiss, ob du sie möchtest.- Yep.
Die Vorhänge behalten wir nicht,
oder, Schatz?
Nein, bist du wahnsinnig?
Aber die Vorhangstange schon.
Da kommen Sachen hervor.
Ei, ei, ei.
Da hat es auch noch eine
Peelingmaschine oder so etwas.
Das ist für die Fingernägel.
- Ja, super.
Ich habe meine gemacht.
Das brauchst du doch nicht.- Nein.
- Ich würde es entsorgen.
Das ist klar.
- Ich brauche es nicht.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist jetzt nicht so angenehm,
aber ...- Nein.
In Gottes Namen.
Ralf hat Corinne
im Internet kennengelernt.
Sie ist seine zweite Frau.
Eineinhalb Jahre
wohnten sie im Thurgau zusammen -
bis zur Auswanderung.
Ich habe mich auch in Steinebrunn,
wo wir zusammenlebten,
wo er auch schon mit seiner Familie,
seiner verstorbenen Frau
und seinem Sohn lebte,
seltsamerweise
von Anfang an wohlgefühlt.
Aber es ist auch
wunder-, wunderschön,
dass wir nun gemeinsam
etwas Neues machen können,
in einem anderen Land.
Hier ist für uns beide alles neu.
Und für uns beide ...
Für uns beide etwas aufzubauen -
das ist ein megaschönes Gefühl.
Die beiden wollen die Schatten der
Vergangenheit hinter sich lassen.
Ta-da!
Das ist unser rostiger Hund.
Wir stellen die mal da runter.
Bisher ist es jedoch nur ein Traum:
das Hundehotel
unter spanischer Sonne.
Dafür haben sie
in der Schweiz alles aufgegeben:
das gemeinsame Haus, die sicheren
Jobs und ihren Freundeskreis.
So.
Gut?
- Super.
Schatz.
- Ah, da seid ihr.
Hast du eine Spritze erhalten?
- Ja, eine in den Po.
Hast du eine erhalten?- Ja.
- Eine schöne, grosse?
Und was ist ...
Wie ich es gesagt habe: eine Spritze
in den Po und jetzt etwas schonen.
Also, heben, Kisten tragen.
Jetzt seid ihr meine Hilfe.
Der Rücken schmerzt zwar noch,
aber Mirabelle und Alain
können nicht länger warten.
Sie wollen zum Wasserturm und nach-
sehen, ob dort alles in Ordnung ist.
Schon mehrfach haben Vandalen
den leerstehenden Turm beschädigt.
Da ist wahnsinnig viel gewachsen.
Da muss man ja durchs Gebüsch.
* Mirabelle lacht. *
Das wird sich noch ändern.
Vor vier Monaten
waren sie das letzte Mal hier.
Also, gehen wir mal rein.
Mal schauen.
Damals hatten sie ihre Pläne
mit den Architekten besprochen.
Ui, man muss lüften.
- Ja, wir müssen lüften.
Es riecht hier drin nicht sehr gut.
Die Luft ist abgestanden, aber sonst
scheint alles in Ordnung zu sein.
Wir gehen mal rauf.
Die Schweizer wollen
den 46 m hohen Turm komplett umbauen.
Neben einem Bed and Breakfast
mit sechs Zimmern
soll ein Café entstehen,
dazu ihre eigene Wohnung.
Doch die Architekten kommen mit den
Plänen für das Baugesuch nicht voran.
Es hängt am Brandschutz. Der Turm ist
zu hoch für die Leiter der Feuerwehr.
Die grösste Überraschung ist,
dass der Lift grösser sein muss.
Das macht sofort ein Mehrfaches aus.
Und - was wir noch ...
das Wasser ...
Für die Sprinkleranlagen müssen wir
rund 150 m3 Wasser im Keller lagern.
Dazu gehören auch Kompressoren
und anderes.
Das wurde nicht gesagt.
Das ist etwas,
was uns jetzt gestört hat.
V.a. wenn hier der Lift rauskommt,
dann ist das hier nicht mehr so ...
Damit fällt eine Attraktion
schon weg.
Die zusätzlichen Auflagen
machen das Projekt viel teurer.
Dabei glaubten die Caboussats,
bestens vorbereitet zu sein.
Schon vor dem Kauf des Turms
im Jahr 2017 hatten sie sich
von Experten beraten lassen und ihr
Vorhaben mit den Behörden diskutiert.
Hast du gesehen?
Es hat sogar Steckdosen.
Die kann man wohl nicht mehr
brauchen.- Die sind topmodern.
Trotz genauer Planung:
Der Umbau ist viel komplizierter
als gedacht.
Der Kimironko Market,
ein geschäftiges Durcheinander
im Herzen Kigalis.
Ich brauche Tomaten.
Ich brauche Salat.
Dianne kommt nicht gerne hierher.
Sie kauft lieber
in kleinen Läden ein.
Doch heute ist alles anders.
Dianne braucht Lebensmittel
für das Willkommensfest,
das sie für ihren
Mann Marco organisiert.
Anders als beim Grossverteiler
in der Schweiz,
wird Dianne der Einkauf
zum Auto getragen.
Eine Annehmlichkeit,
an die sie sich schnell gewöhnte.
Auch sonst sieht Dianne in Ruanda
mehr Möglichkeiten.
25 Jahre nach ihrer Flucht
befindet sich das Land im Aufschwung.
In erste Linie
ist es einfach Homeland.
Und ...
Ich kann hier mehr machen
als in der Schweiz.
Ich bin überfordert,
aber in einem postiven Sinn.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Zurück in Kajagari, einem Wohn-
quartier des unteren Mittelstands.
Hier hat Dianne
ein möbliertes Haus gemietet.
Zwei Köche und Diannes
beste Freundin helfen vorbereiten.
20 Leute
hat sie zur Party eingeladen.
Er ist der Küchenchef
für das Fleisch.
Für den gemeinsamen Start in Ruanda
soll alles perfekt sein.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Ah, ich freue mich,
dass ich nicht mehr allein bin.
Ich hatte so viel Zeit allein.
Das ist nicht ... Es ist mühsam.
Am Wochenende allein,
während der Woche allein.
Ich freu mich,
dass ich jemanden hier habe,
dass Marco kommt.
* Drollige Handorgelklänge *
* Rhythmische Trommelmusik *
Und dann ist es so weit.
Marco kommt in Kigali an.
Die Heimat seiner Frau kennt
der 51-jährige Ingenieur gut -
aus vielen gemeinsamen Ferien.
Ja, also, puh ...
Das Zeug hinstellen, absitzen
und mit meiner Frau
ein Bier trinken.
Darauf freue ich mich.
Einfache Dinge,
nichts Kompliziertes.
* Marco lacht. *
Zu Hause ankommen,
* Sanfte Musik *
So, welcome.
Welcome.
Noch ahnt Marco nicht,
was ihn erwartet.
(Beide) Eh!
- Salü.
* Kuss *
22 Jahre verheiratet - und verliebt
fast wie am ersten Tag.
I've waited for you.
Welcome home, Schätzchen.
Danke.
- Alles gut?
Alles gut, Schätzchen.
- Gut gereist?- Ja.
Du siehst gut aus.
- Oh, danke.
Habe ich für dich gemacht.
* Beide lachen. *
Hello.
* Jubel *
Oh, my god.
* Applaus und Lachen *
Wow!
Hello.
Annette.
Dianne hat nicht nur Verwandte
und Freunde zusammengetrommelt.
Auch die Nachbarn sind gekommen.
(Englisch)
Mützingi.
* Dianne lacht. *
(Englisch)
Endlich.
* Die Kirchturmuhr schlägt,
Möwen kreischen. *
Eine Woche ist Familie Caboussat
inzwischen in Cuxhaven.
Und für einmal geht es bei ihnen
nicht um den Wasserturm.
* Surren der Kaffeemaschine *
* Klopfen *
Du musst aufstehen.
Die Sommerferien sind zu Ende.
Yannis und sein Bruder Nicolas
müssen in die Schule.
Ich bin schon auch etwas nervös.
Ja ...
Ich hoffe wirklich
das Beste für sie,
dass sie gute Freunde finden,
gute Lehrer
und dass sie sich
gut integrieren können.
Das ist im Moment das A und O.
Was ich sicher mitnehmen würde ...
... ein Heft, ein Etui ...
... einen Massstab.
Man weiss nie ...
Damit du die Sachen notieren kannst,
die du brauchst und haben musst.
Ja, ja.
Yannis startet in die achte Klasse
der Realschule.
Alles Gute.
Wohin muss ich?
- Um die Ecke.
Sein Bruder geht - neu -
auf die Berufsbildungsschule.
So.
Also.
Mit seinen Jungs hatte Alain
am Vorabend noch telefoniert.
Jetzt muss er sich in Bern
auf seinen Job konzentrieren.
C'est tout en ordre?
- Oui, ça va bien.
Entschuldigung, haben Sie gesehen,
hinter dem GOP-Ständer
ist es noch schmutzig.
Das ist der Ständer
dort beim Pfosten. Vielen Dank.
In 10 Min. öffnet die SINDEX ―
eine Technologiemesse.
Alain ist Messeleiter und als Chef
für den reibungslosen Ablauf
der Veranstaltung verantwortlich.
Bei so einer Messe
geht es immer um sehr viel Geld
und um viele Menschen.
Das müssen wir
einfach perfekt machen.
Ich wäre lieber bei meiner Familie,
aber es hat sich halt so ergeben.
Wir machen auf -
in 30 Sek. ist es so weit.
Alain hat seine Festanstellung
bereits gekündigt.
Er wird seine Dienste jedoch
als Selbstständiger weiter anbieten.
Nur so kommen Caboussats
in Cuxhaven über die Runden.
(Frau) Hallo.
- (Ralf) Hallo, Morgen.
Eine Journalistin
von den "Costa Nachrichten"
ist auf die Auswanderer aus
der Ostschweiz aufmerksam geworden.
Guten Morgen. Corinne. Hallo.
- Guten Morgen.
Noch einen Kaffee oder so?
Sie will einen Bericht
über Corinne und Ralf
und deren Pläne
für das Hundehotel schreiben.
Okay, dann erzählen Sie doch mal.
Das Hundehotel
besteht aus Elementbauten,
die wir von einem
Schweizer Architekten kaufen können.
Die kann man dann
beliebig erweitern.
Wir möchten das Haus nicht so haben,
wie es hier ist -
mit diesen Sandwichplatten.
(Corinne) Wir werden das auskleiden.
- Mit Holzplatten.
Und dann wird es bunt bemalt.
Die Böden werden mit ...
... Laminat ...
- ... Linoleum belegt.
Damit es nachher wirklich
wie ein ...
... Hotel aussieht.
Es sieht danach aus
wie ein Schweizer Chalet.
Sechs verschiedene Themenzimmer
für zwölf Hunde wollen sie bauen.
Ralf möchte dabei
so viel wie möglich selbst machen.
Hier haben wir ...
Hier haben wir dann
die Einfahrt für die Kunden.
Hier wird es Parkplätze geben.
Auf diesem Stück
entsteht dann das Hundehotel.
Es wird da hinten
zum Nachbarn hin ...
Das ganze Grundstück bis zu den
Masten wird für die Hunde da sein -
mit Spielwiese und Pool und ...
Hatten Sie schon Kontakt
zu den Nachbarn?
Die Nachbarn erhalten noch
einen Brief von der Gemeinde.
Der Bau wird noch
20 Tage lang ausgeschrieben.
Die Nachbarn
werden also noch informiert.
Genau.
- Das ist das Nächste.
Wir werden die Nachbarn begrüssen.
(Spanisch)
Noch ist Caruso allein.
Geht es nach Waldburgers,
wird sich das rasch ändern.
Schon in sechs Monaten
wollen sie ihr Hundehotel eröffnen.
Durchschnittstemperatur 22 °C,
das ganze Jahr hindurch.
Das ist der neue Alltag
für Schommers in Kigali.
Herrlich, herrlich.
Statt Novembertristesse.
Das ist herrlich.
Das ist einfach lecker.
Viel Zeit, die angenehmen Seiten Ru-
andas zu geniessen, haben sie nicht.
Sie müssen Räume
für das Fitnessstudio finden -
und ein Haus,
in dem sie künftig wohnen können.
Schauen wir mal,
wo dieser Container steckt.
Mein Freiluftbüro.
Marco und Dianne
haben ihren gesamten Hausrat
und die Geräte für das Fitnessstudio
nach Ruanda verschifft.
"Container information" -
so, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Oh Gott, nein!
Oh nein.
Ja, das sind keine guten News.
Der Container
hat bereits drei Wochen Verspätung.
Schnuggeli, kannst du kurz kommen?
- Ja.
Schau mal hier:
"Vessel arrival in Dar-es-Salaam".
Schau dir mal das Datum an:
27. Dezember.
Oh mein Gott.
Hast du deine Unterhosen
hier im Koffer?
Wenn du die nicht hast,
bist du am Arsch.
Dann musst du eine waschen
und gleich wieder anziehen.
Aber ich habe einfach Angst,
dass der Container
noch später ankommt.
Ja.- Du musst ja
mit dem Fitness anfangen können.
Also, du kannst schon anfangen ...
- Ich will im Januar anfangen.
Das bedeutet, es wird jetzt Februar.
Es wird mehr oder weniger
Mitte Januar,
bis das installiert ist.
Ja, das wird sicher Februar, März.
- Du brauchst schon Zeit.
Ja, welcome to Africa.
Der Wasserturm gehört schon fest
zum neuen Leben der Caboussats,
auch wenn sie von der Umsetzung ihres
Projektes noch weit entfernt sind.
Mirabelle hat per Mail
ein erstes Angebot
für einen grösseren Lift bekommen.
Es sind welche gekommen,
die sich angesehen haben,
wie es zu machen ist.
Es sind auch Brandschutzsachen
zum Vorschein gekommen,
die wieder Fragen aufgeworfen haben.
Es ist manchmal recht aufwendig,
zum Ziel zu kommen.
* Sie lacht. *
Aber das reicht noch nicht.
Wir müssen mehr einholen.
Man muss meist
an verschiedenen Orten anfragen.
Aber Schindler wäre schon mal gut.
Ordner um Ordner
haben sie inzwischen angesammelt,
doch über die Planungsphase kommen
die Auswanderer bisher nicht hinaus.
Hallo.
- (Nicolas) Hallo.
Schon da?
- Ja.
Seit wann bist du hier?
- Seit etwa 10 Min.
Es ist megapraktisch:
Ab 9 Uhr Schule bis etwa 11.30 Uhr.
Echt?- Ja,
wir haben nachmittags keine Schule.
Hallo.
- (Yannis) Hallo.
Die Feuertaufe hast du bestanden.
Gehst du bitte nach hinten?
Der erste Schultag ist zu Ende.
Ich hätte es schwerer eingeschätzt.
Ich hätte es nicht so eingeschätzt,
wie's war.
Heute war es wirklich einfach.
Anfangs war ich schon nervös,
aber dann ...
Wir gingen ins Klassenzimmer,
der Lehrer redete die ganze Zeit.
Da sah man automatisch
die neuen Gesichter.
Das hat mich automatisch beruhigt.
Ja, ich denke,
ich habe das mal gut gemeistert.
Ja.
Und ihr sucht euch wirklich noch
eine Sportart aus,
die ihr hier betreiben könnt.
Ja, ja.
- Du hast schon was gesagt.
Nicht Volleyball,
sondern Beachvolleyball.
Eine Sorge weniger.
Zumindest bei Yannis und Nicolas
läuft alles nach Plan.
In Spanien arbeiten Waldburgers
ihre Pendenzenliste ab.
Corinnes Mutter Marianne
unterstützt sie dabei.
Im Rathaus in Benissa wollen sich
die Neuankömmlinge registrieren.
(Ralf) Hola, gracias.
Das ist nicht hier, das ist
gar nicht auf der Gemeinde selbst.
Das ist ein separates Büro.
- Also müssen wir da langgehen.
Also müssen wir ...
- Gehen wir zurück. No problem.
(Vater) Mir nach.
- (Corinne) Ich komme gleich.
Seltsam, dass das nicht
auf der Gemeinde selbst ist.
Ich komme.
(Ralf) Corinne spricht Spanisch,
aber Marianne kann es etwas besser.
Die Verständigung
klappt sicher besser,
als wenn wir allein gehen würden.
Hier wieder rechts.
Corinnes Eltern leben bereits
seit 15 Jahren an der Costa Blanca.
Sie schätzen das milde Klima und
die günstigen Lebenshaltungskosten -
genau wie Tausende andere Auswanderer
aus Mitteleuropa.
Super.
Hola.
Corinne und Ralf
brauchen eine Wohnsitzbestätigung.
Nur so können sie später die
Aufenthaltsbewilligung beantragen.
Ich bin im Moment noch etwas nervös,
aber ich freue mich richtig darauf,
endlich wieder
einen Wohnsitz zu haben.
Si. Du musst schauen,
ob alles korrekt ist.
Da brauche ich eine Brille.
- Ich habe eine.
Du könntest auch schauen.
- Dein Gebrüll.
Das heisst 20.
Dein Geburtsdatum,
die Telefonnummer.
Ist gut.
- Ihr müsst hier unterschreiben.
Gracias.
Jetzt gehören wir dazu.
- Ihr seid jetzt Benissaner.
Benissa an, genau.
Wir sind offiziell hier.
Muchas gracias.
- Gracias.
Alles tipptopp. Bei Waldburgers
läuft es wie geschmiert.
Wir brauchen ein Postfach
für Briefe aus der Schweiz.
Genau, einfach keine Rechnungen.
- Nein.
In Ruanda bekommen
die Solothurner Auswanderer Besuch.
Hallo.
- He, Pastor. Welcome.
* Sie sprechen Kinyarwanda. *
Den Pastor hat Dianne organisiert.
Das ist Pastor Innocent,
der mit uns kommt,
um mit uns ...
... quasi zu beten, dass bei
unseren Projekten alles gut geht.
Darum ist er heute
mit uns unterwegs.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Hier ist es richtig wild.
Man glaubt, man sei in der Wildnis.
Schommers erhalten den Segen
nicht einfach irgendwo.
Pastor Innocent
möchte zu einem Kraftort gehen,
eine Autostunde von Kigali entfernt.
So.
Jetzt sind wir
bei den Rusumo-Wasserfällen.
Ich sehe keinen Wasserfall mehr.
- Siehst du keinen Wasserfall mehr?
Sie haben uns
den Wasserfall geklaut.
Ich muss ...
- Die bauen hier.
Der Weg zum Wasserfall ist versperrt.
Doch so schnell
geben die drei nicht auf.
Es wird noch etwas abenteuerlich.
- Mhm.
(Englisch)
Das ist wandern pur.
(Lachend) Wandern pur.
Uff!
* Sie spricht Kinyarwanda. *
(Englisch)
Es ist gefährlich.
Schnuggeli.
Wenn man vom Dorf her ... Schau mal,
es gibt einen Weg vom Dorf her.
Siehst du ihn, den Fluss entlang?
Noch ein letzter Versuch.
(Englisch)
Wir gehen zusammen alle runter.
* Marco lacht. *
Ich gehe allein, das ist besser.
- Sicher nicht.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Und siehe da.
Aber das ist gut hier, oder nicht?
Ja.
* Gebet *
Vielleicht ahnen es
Schommers bereits:
Den Segen des Pastors
können sie noch gut gebrauchen.
* Gebet *
* Sanfte Musik setzt ein. *
Ah ...
Ich bin ja
am Bodensee aufgewachsen
Das Wasser
ist ein wichtiges Element.
Und ...
Wir dachten, wenn wir auswandern,
dann müssen wir irgendwo
Wasser in der Nähe haben.
Das Meer ist immer etwas Spezielles.
Es ist ... Das braucht es.
Ich brauche es.
Oder?
Der hier ist gigantisch. Nicht?
Calpe mit dem Penyal d'Ilfac
hat es Ralf angetan.
Bereits in den ersten gemeinsamen
Ferien mit Corinne war für ihn klar:
Hier möchte er irgendwann leben.
* Sanfte Klavier- und Gitarrenmusik *
Hola!- (Frau) Hola.
- Dos Apérol Spritz.
Muchas gracias.
(Spanisch)
So, Schätzchen.
Unser erster Apérol ...
... in unserer neuen Heimat.
- In unserer neuen Heimat.
Salud.
- Salud.
Eigentlich unglaublich:
Bis vor Kurzem
war Ralf noch Chef über das
Ersatzteillager in einem Autohaus.
So etwas Leckeres.
Und Corinne arbeitete als Sachbear-
beiterin in einem Industriebetrieb.
Bis jetzt ist alles super gelaufen.
Das ist etwas beängstigend.
Aber irgendwie ...
- Alles zack, zack.
Wir sind guten Mutes.
- Ja.
Da bleiben wir dran,
damit es gut läuft.
Positiv denken - dann kommt es gut.
- Ja, sicher.
Es kommt gut, das weiss ich.
Gibt es ein Problem, dann packen wir
es an, wenn es kommt.
Wir machen uns keine Gedanken,
was sein kann oder wird.
Das weiss man nie.
Das weiss man nie im Leben.
Genau. Es gibt keine Probleme,
es gibt nur Lösungen.
Noch blicken Waldburgers
voller Zuversicht in die Zukunft.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Oh!
* Piepen *
Oh, là là.
Hello.- Mwiriwe.
- Mwiriwe.
Dianne und Marco haben nur noch
wenige Wochen Zeit,
für sich ein neues Haus in Kigali
zu finden.
Dann müssen sie aus
ihrer bisherigen Bleibe ausziehen.
Eine Vermittlerin zeigt ihnen
verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
(Englisch)
Oh, Gott.
Toilette.
* Die Frau spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Will man ein Haus verkaufen, sollte
man es zumindest etwas putzen.
Ja.
- Finde ich.
Der Balkon ist auch nicht schlecht.
Einfach diese ....
Die sind Wahnsinn. Schau mal.
Die sind massiv.
Das ist ja wahnsinnig.
Dafür hat es keinen Schutz vor den
Fenstern. Da kann jeder einsteigen.
Von daher ist es ...
Parkplätze hat es genug,
man kann bis hinten fahren.
Ja, ja. Platz hat es genügend.
Man sieht ins Land hinaus,
die Reisfelder.
Das Haus hat fünf Schlafzimmer
und kostet 1'200 $ im Monat.
* Glockige Musik *
Ein hoher Preis ...
... für das, was es bietet.
* Glockige Musik *
Ich bin nicht zufrieden.
Du bist nicht zufrieden?
- Nein.
* Sie spricht Kinyarwanda. *
Okay, okay.
Nächste Woche bei "Auf und davon":
Baustelle pur.
- Baustelle pur.
Schommers finden in Ruanda
passende Räumlichkeiten.
Innert weniger Wochen
muss aus der ehemaligen Bar
ein Fitnessstudio werden.
Es muss im März fertig sein.
Ich weiss nicht ...
In Spanien gibt es bei Waldburgers
Probleme mit der Baubewilligung
für das Hundehotel.
Die Nachbarn wehren sich
gegen die Pläne der Schweizer.
Es ist ein seltsames Gefühl:
Noch nicht recht angekommen
und schon hat man
die Nachbarn gegen sich.
Und an der Nordsee stockt die Planung
mit dem Wasserturm nach wie vor.
Familie Caboussat
will jedoch nicht mehr länger warten.
Irgendwie gibt es ein gutes Gefühl.
Es geschieht etwas.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt
# und chöme nümme hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für nes nöis Dahei.
# Si göh hüt nu uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
A. Werlen, D. McMinn - 2021
# Uf u dervo!